>> You've done a lot so far and let's just summarize what happened when we added
this outlier to the dataset. The mean changed from 47,718 when we just looked at
these to 123,098 when we looked at all of them. However, the median only changed
from 48,670 for that, to 50,915. This tendency of the median is called robust.
In everyday language, robust means strong and sturdy, which makes sense for its
statistical definition. It's not affected much by departures from the norm. So
now, you've learned about the mean, the median, and the mode. These are all
measures of center because they typically describe the center of the
distribution. As you've seen though sometimes, the mean doesn't describe the
center because of an outlier. Sometimes, the mode doesn't describe the center
and the median doesn't take every data point into account. However, in the case
of the starting salaries from the University of North Carolina, the median might
have been a better statistic to determine what starting salary you would have
made as a Geography major in the 1980s. The median is always the best measure of
central tendency when dealing with highly skewed distributions.